[Musique]
les rapaces qui tourne autour l'
ambiance ambiance bizarre ici
on appelle cette île où une quand jim à
ça veut dire lille navires de guerre on
l'appelle aussi lille silencieuse
ça c'est gigantesque là les appartements
il y avait tout ce qu'il fallait ici
[Musique]
on arrive on arrive alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ici ils ont trouvé du
charbon à la fin du 19e ils ont
construit des immeubles
et dans les années 60 il ya 6000
personnes qui habitaient sur l'île
c'était à l'époque la plus grosse
densité de population au monde
72 une année avant que les gens partent
il a été complètement abandonné en
quelques mois et c'est vide et parce
qu'ils ont décidé d'arrêter
l'exploitation du charbon sur l'île
[Musique]
ça va être quelque chose d'habiter là
ou alors bienvenue au japon pour une
exploration de l'habitat de l'archipel
une exploration en grand écart entre le
passé
l'éternel présent et puis les maisons du
futur
ça commence fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
on m'avait dit au japon il faut
commencer zen alors j'ai choisi de
commencer par un bonsaï
[Musique]
si c'est un des plus vieux os en scène
du japon les hauts-de-seine c'est la
source d'eau chaude sur thermale
c'est une maison qui a 150 ans époque
meiji c'est une architecture typique
avec les fenêtres en arc de cercle
totalement construit en faux si près du
japon face à la team qui un bâtiment
magnifique
[Musique]
bon le japon c 130 clients d'habitants
sur un archipel très montagneux mine de
rien et japonais ils sont ainsi sur les
volcans
un quart des tremblements de terre
enregistrés dans le monde sait ici on
savait la pression en quelques secondes
votre maison peut disparaître
il ya des villes qui ont été
complètement rasée bombardé pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale il a fallu tout
reconstruire
j'ai parfois l'impression qu'ici on
construit les maisons où l'on peut et
comme on veut les avoir
[Musique]
oh
c'est mon premier voyage au japon j'ai
débarqué avec des tonnes d'image je m'en
doutais un peu mais là c'est vraiment la
claque
au japon la surprise est à chaque coin
de rue
partie de l'île abandonné 2 gunkanjima
je commence mon exploration des maisons
japonaises au sud de l'archipel dans
l'île de kyushu
[Musique]
je
hahaha
un beau centre de la ville tomtom
et qui paraît tout à fait classique mais
[Musique]
comment sonne bonjour c'est une maison
pour un couple et un chien un couple de
retraités plus exactement bonjour
monsieur est un ancien policier madame
était infirmière l'architecte sous
fujimoto leur a fait une maison sur
mesure
[Musique]
le soleil se lève de ce côté-ci de la
maison
et ensuite tout au long de la journée la
lumière change petit à petit c'est un
vrai spectacle
[Musique]
c'est curieux moi j'étais vraiment elle
est extraordinaire mais non alors j'ai
envie de voir
c'est un jardin intérieur en fait
[Musique]
va-t-il aussi le matin je viens prendre
mon café ici sur cette petite table je
suis dans un bain de soleil c'est
vraiment très agréable
quand moi j'ai vu les photos de votre
maison je pensais que c'était un jeune
couple japonais qui vivent à l'intérieur
oui tout le monde nous dit ça vous savez
tout le monde est surpris de voir qu'on
est cet âge vous êtes très jeune c'est
parce que j'ai voulu
souvent les gens sont intrigués quand
ils nous voient dans cette vision coucou
est jugé
mais en fin de compte il admire ce que
nous avons fait
on visite l'intérieur d'abord
au japon même les classes moyennes sont
appel aux architectes pour construire
leurs maisons parfois vraiment
expérimental
c'est dedans et dehors ils ont
complètement cassé le cloisonnement il
est de la boîte
classique c'est une sensation géniale
ici
on nous voit beaucoup moins que ce qu'on
pense
et quand on se tient ici on sent
pourtant la présence des gens à
l'extérieur
ils sont pour cela se sentir enfermé
c'est agréable
ça fait 3 3 couches quoi trois volumes
trois boîtes l'une dans l'autre
oui c'est ça ça fait trois mots du
emboîtés les uns dans les autres
[Musique]
vous voyez là-bas le nid d'oiseau au
sommet de l'arbre il y à un nid
[Musique]
en ce moment il ya les oisillons qui
attendent la becquée je les vois bien
quand je prend le petit déjeuner
on se sent bien dans votre maison alors
on regarde ça c'est votre chambre là
[Rires]
[Musique]
lessard olala c'est très très beau
très très beau centre ville là et tu te
retiens pas s'endormir dans la forêt
quand c'est quand c'est ans avec les
feuilles l'assemblée extraordinaire oui
c'est très beau
en ce moment avec le printemps les
feuilles grossistes de jour en jour
regardez ces petits bourgeons je les
observais le matin quand je me lève
c'est très agréable
en habitant dans cette maison on sent
qu'on fait partie de l'univers si j'ose
dire le fait de voir le ciel nous apaise
[Musique]
et comment on fait pour laver les vitres
comment vous l'avez c'est vous qui
faites le ménage là ou pas possible
c'est vous parce que c'est moi
je voulais voir ça
jardin extérieur qui fait le tour de la
maison
à l'elysée
à
andré gall incroyable
[Musique]
vous avez beaucoup de chance a vous avez
beaucoup de chance d'avoir une maison
comme ça et oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
plus d'infos
ils vont s'en fout oui c'est moi un vrai
bonheur cette maison je reste très bien
peut feuilleter les albums photos de
harumi
[Musique]
mais j'ai encore beaucoup de merveilles
à découvrir
j'ai entendu parler par exemple d'une
chaumière une chambre d'hôte incroyable
perdu au fin fond des montagnes
japonaise
quand je dis au fin fond des montagnes
c'est vraiment au fin fond des montagnes
une heure de ferry pour arriver sur
l'île puis six heures de route sur des
chemins qui se resserre de plus en plus
[Musique]
bon on est sur l'île de shikoku
cellulite qui restait très à l'écart
dans le japon là c'est un endroit
vraiment historiquement un des plus
pauvres du japon
on est dans l'autre sens on sort mais en
train de se faire là c'est le haut
parleur parce que je prends le pont dans
le mauvais sens on refait ça on revient
revient à ok ok
c'est beautiful ah ouais c'est bon c'est
bon
tu vois un souvenir extraordinaire
à
[Musique]
à 1000 mètres d'altitude au milieu des
bambous et des cyprès shiori la maison
de la flûte
c'est alex caire un écrivain d'origine
américaine qui a eu le coup de foudre
pour cette ancienne ferme dans les
années 70
il a réhabilité cette maison pour en
faire une chambre d'hôte et s'épaulent
catho qui s'occupe maintenant de la
maison
[Musique]
c'est incroyable la longueur de cette
poutre
c'était un très gros
c'était un bel arbre ça vient depuis la
cuisine et ce à travers toute la pièce
ce qui est intéressant c'est la
charpente qui est épineux du japon c'est
à dire que pour limiter à porter les
poutres il ya d'un système de poteaux
jeu qu'au japon on commence par
construire les maisons faisant un toit
et ont fait des poteaux un toit et
ensuite ça permet de pas avoir de murs
et donc d'avoir ses cloisons mobiles de
laisser entrer la lumière de faire des
parties modulable pendant un poteau ici
un peu tôt ici et donc deux poutres dans
ce sens là et sa coupe la portée de la
troisième au dessus ça permet d'avoir un
grand espace dégagé autre cadeau qu'est
ce que c'est comme moi c'est du sourire
oui c'est du cèdre du suisse
avait planché c'est du pin wakamatsu en
japonais un bois plutôt rare
le calcul avant il y avait des cloisons
ici oui des shoji ces fameuses cloisons
mobiles
c'est vraiment modulable vous pouvez
faire une infinité de choses il ya
beaucoup de possibilités
une petite chambre tranquille avec un
peu de bazar
les anciens pouvait avoir la chambre ici
ou là il pouvait avoir plusieurs pièces
c'est vraiment flexible c'est bien ces
chambres là ça dégage d'un grand espace
central et après tu dors où tu veux
l'espace central reste vide il n'y a pas
de meubles
desiage à cette maison vous français
elle a probablement été construite
autour des années 1700
donc c'est qu'un dg très très vieille
maison
[Musique]
voilà la meilleure position au vraiment
sentir la musique evous japonaises elles
sont dessinées pour ce regard sur le
paysage on est toujours ainsi comme ça
donc quand on marche en hauteur on perd
tous là on a on a la vue sur le paysage
when you look quand on regarde et à la
même distance entre les poutres et le
paysage comme ça donne une sorte de
symétrie str ses matches et bien on se
trouve à mi hauteur des cloisons moins
bien mes cheveux
donc là il ya la grande pièce est à côté
la partie cuisine
avec les claude choquet
[Musique]
oh
ces décos ici
[Musique]
wallez le toit en chaume c'est une ère
de local
oui c'est du chaume vous voyez c'est la
plante qui pousse là bas cette sorte de
page
japonais on l'appelle susuki contre le
push
à l'automne un coût de cette herbe et
elle sèche pendant l'hiver
au printemps les gens se rassemblent
pour réparer les toitures
chaque printemps vous savez que les gens
du village vont venir nous aider c'est
une forme d'entrée collective cette
année on va remplacer ce soit l'année
suivante un autre
il personne ne se fait payer parce
qu'ils savent que ça change
quand ça sera leur tour y z'ont du monde
pour venir les aider
vous avez besoin d aide
oui apportons tous à la barre
non
l'altitude et le feu là oblige un retour
à la vie communautaire
et multigénérationnel
froid
les maisons du secteur ont le même genre
de feu à l'intérieur
si vous n'avez pas de feu alors la
toiture de vieux tubes
qu'on danse
très vite ce n'est pas ça et la fumée du
feu c'est marrant éloigne les petits
animaux c'est une protection
équipe ça
protège le toit contre les insectes
sorte d'autorégulation de la maison en
fait si on fait du feu tous les jours la
toiture reste en bon état pour une
soixantaine d'années
[Musique]
désormais mythique là
je me demande c'est pas ça qui m sur la
croyance
c'est peut-être directement sac qui met
sur le toit des monastères
ont le savoir-faire de la construction
en bois au japon ça date pas d'hier
là je viens voir akuma no 1 des plus
vieux bâtiments en bois du monde
j'ai rendez vous avec monsieur assaillis
à 77 ans est le grand prêtre du
sanctuaire shinto de kuma no
[Musique]
il ya déjà ça
je vais vous débarrasser des mauvais
sort
[Musique]
on met au coeur du sanctuaire saint
priest de khumalo
ça quoi
oui c'est un cerisier pleureur
regardez la floraison est passé les
feuilles sont déjà sortis à temps
pour le monde cet arbre est de l'époque
muromachi donc il y à peu près 800 ans
dans les charpentes là les poutres en y
as assez ou sanctuaires
là bas il ya l'autel de la déesse isana
me on voit bien les cinq hôtels aligner
le dernier c'est celui de la déesse
amaterasu rock à l'intéressant c'est la
déesse du soleil au japon
la toiture est recouverte de morceaux
des portes de cèdre du japon cellino qui
c'est du faux si près du japon il
obtient 7 bardage en inoki mais sait
on les fixe un par un clou et mousse
tout d'abord d'autres défis c'est
l'épaisseur l'épaisseur c'est sincère
[Musique]
on peut voir plus près là le travail sur
le bardage
soit n'y fit
je peux regarder
on va pas rentrer dans le sanctuaire
shinto évidemment mais là je veux voir
le bardage parce que là
en tout 40 cm on pousse avec les les
formes rondes comme ça et pourquoi ça a
des formes rondes pourquoi c'est
pourquoi le bord du toit relève
dans un sanctuaire les lignes ne sont
pas droites elles sont plutôt fluide
c'est pour donner une impression de
douceur
si vous voulez je vous fait visiter
l'intérieur reçoit bien
venez venez
incroyable à l'intérieur de son père
derrière cette palissade de bois rose la
partie la plus sacrée du sanctuaire elle
est réservée normalement aux officiels
et aux chefs religieux du shintô isme
[Musique]
c'est la beauté de l'architecturé moi
mais ça c'est incroyable
personne ne fait ça au monde c'est les
seuls
[Musique]
ici nous sommes dans la partie la plus
ancienne du sanctuaire
rien n'a changé depuis l'époque
muromachi il ya 800 ans
et gâteaux vous savez c'est la première
fois que je fais rentrer un étranger ici
entre le japon et la france c'est une
longue histoire
[Musique]
et il ya un autre étranger qui vit ici
avant moi c'est andré malraux
et vous malraux quand il est venu ici là
vous l'avez rencontré vos malraux je me
souviens bien d'andré malraux il portait
son imperméable mobile sous la pluie il
contemplait la cascade
[Musique]
la
mongolie
bon là on est à kyoto un million et demi
d'habitants
c'est un des coeurs historique et
culturel de l'archipel c'est l'ancienne
capitale du japon
et en surnomme kyoto la ville aux mille
temple
[Musique]
ouais ça c'est de la pub quand il faut
savoir que c'est très beau et très
esthétique mais c'est la promo et les
sponsors qui donne de l'argent pour le
cynisme et les noms de banques et les
entreprises et particuliers aussi
c'est assez beau savoir un effet quoi
[Musique]
j'ai rendez vous dans la maison de
monsieur hayakawa c'est une des plus
grandes fortunes du pays il habite le
quartier le plus préservé et le plus
authentique de kyoto
tous les matins vous venez ici la vie
j'adore ce paysage
[Musique]
c'est pour toutes cette mousse l'art
merci de nous accueillir dans votre
maison
[Musique]
ça donnerait
aucun meuble c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
cette pièce a été conçue pour admirer la
forêt de bambous
la forêt appartient au sanctuaire de la
famille impériale construit il ya 1200
ans
en règle générale l'architecturé
japonaise réuni l'extérieur et
l'intérieur tout est ouvert le jardin
fait partie de l' architecture et vice
versa
[Musique]
en une pièce away
et voilà
j'adore ça j'adore cela
il assure que c'est beau
c'est quoi cette matière
c'est un mur de terre tous les murs de
la maison sont en terre de la terre
mélangée avec de la paille
diaries c'est un vase japonais très
vieux
il a mille deux cents enfants
zen partout
[Musique]
dans la baignoire tout en bois massif
au premier étage il y a les chambres
enfin le salon principal disons
[Musique]
et vous dormez ou alors vous dormez sur
des tatamis aussi sur des futons triton
oui on dort sur des futons dans cette
pièce
tu en
voilà
pour les tatamis sont d'origine
là ils ont 84
90 ans que je cela naturel
qui sont intactes 90 ans
[Musique]
on m'a dit que la taille des pièces
étaient déterminés par les tatamis mais
oui salles
différentes combinaisons
dans cette pièce par exemple
il y a dit a mis
d'accord il y en a 3 puis 7 autour
et du coup c'est ce qui détermine la
taille de la pièce en elle même
e
c'est de la découvrir il ya peu de
choses même
comme cette impression d'espacé
d'ouverture est tout et quelques objets
très très bon c'est ça l'idée du
cnc ville tu à l'esprit reposé et de
temps en temps tu te concentres sur un
objet magnifique quoi
c'est une règle de décoration qui est
dur à tenir on a tendance à en pied
plein de choses dans nos maisons à d et
agir partout on a des bouquins n'y a pas
un livre monsieur je suis sûr qu'il en a
plein qui sont rangés dans les placards
ce qui revient de très cultivé tout n'y
a rien
c'est là c'est la règle c'est la
boutique oise est naze
c'est une vision globale
l'harmonie un mois on appelle ça le bois
ni
[Musique]
cette partie de la pièce est la plus
importante de toute la maison en trois
les cloisons coulissantes sont conçus
pour jouer avec la lumière et londres
rester ici et vous verrez que tout va
changer petit à petit
[Musique]
un jour j c'est la transparence hier que
ça laisse entrer la lumière tout en
coupant la vision de l'extérieur et ça
fait rentrer une lumière tamisée dans la
pièce
c'est cette lumière là qui met en valeur
les objets d'art les brillances et c'est
lié à tout travail sur la lac la dorure
c'est agréable c'est reposant cssa
avec pato
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais à quoi le speed parce qu'il à
temps plein d'invités là il est en train
d'organiser un repas ingres absolument
incroyable le prix varie à peu près
entre sept et dix mille euros par
personne
et oui sert une cuisine qui date de
l'époque de l'empereur il ya 400 ans et
c'est aujourd'hui et nous a invité à ce
repas
je ne sais pas ce que ça va donner mais
j'ai un peu l'impression
[Musique]
monsieur hayakawa et passionnée de
cuisine historique en réserve plus d'un
an à l'avancé pour manger chez lui
comment manger autant des empereurs
certain qu'on ville sacrifie plus d'un
mois de salaire interdiction bien sûr
d'assister à la préparation des plats on
m'invite à partager les entrées à
condition que je me tienne un peu à
l'écart
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
château
[Musique]
c'est très raffinées comme souvent cette
saison
c'est marrant parce que là on mange dans
la chambre quand même ça étonnant c'est
vraiment concernés de la modularité une
fois que tu as rangé les futons la pièce
devient place à vivre
dans la chambre
là
qu'est ce que c'est ça l'amusé takano
qu'auprès de bonbons c'est bon bout on
va le récupérer dans la dans la forêt à
côté là il faudrait beaucoup puis en
cuisine
alors le bambou moi mais ça sert aussi à
fabriquer la maison
des chevrons de la toiture c'est en
lambeaux
après deux heures de mise en bouche
c'est l'heure tant attendue des sushis
[Musique]
[Rires]
il assure monsieur hayakawa
c'est la culture japonaise
traditionnelle
dans l'habitat cuisine
c'est l'heure pour moi de quitter les
tatamis
dommages à venir après les sushis des
plats incroyable comme le célèbre boeuf
de omis élevé à la musique classique est
massée à la bière pour faire pénétrer la
grèce à l'intérieur du musée
moi je file sous d'autres cieux les
papilles encore excité par ce cadeau
gastronomique
[Musique]
bon ben ça y est je suis dans la plus
grande agglomération du monde 37
millions d'habitants quand même si on
compte la ville ininterrompue qui a tout
autour de la baie de tokyo
à tokyo il n'y a pas de centre le centre
c'est le palais de l'empereur c'est une
zone interdite
et tout autour d'un urbanisme anarchique
chaotique il peut en vrac avec des
maisons qui sont très différentes les
unes des autres
[Musique]
dans le quartier c'est à gaillac houle
un quartier mixte avec des gens qui ont
de l'argent des artistes c'est un
quartier où la population est très
mélangées n'a pas beaucoup de place il
ya des toutes petites maisons et à plein
de gens qui habitent ensemble dans les
condominiums les immeubles collectifs
ici les maisons elles sont entassées les
unes sur les autres parce que le prix du
terrain est très cher
c'est ça c'est le barbecue
qu'est ce que c'est
pas d'accord c'est les poubelles
elles s'inclinent leurs poubelles ah
ouais
c'est du costaud même les petits bals
sont clean ici
[Musique]
bon à savoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on est chez les cool pas de problème
en bas il ya des bureaux et au premier
étage il y a des appartements
[Musique]
alessio
ranger
[Musique]
ça va vite les chantiers au japon
vous savez on aura monté le toit d'ici
deux semaines il faut venir chez moi à
construire ma maison parce que moi ça
avance moins vite
[Rires]
ok
arigato
[Applaudissements]
ça va
en fait partout s'affranchit difficile
très très vite
un labyrinthe de ruelles
bref je suis dit howard l'ultra
contemporain du moderne et high tech ici
il ya des maisons vraiment délirante
par exemple et la maison science fiction
[Musique]
vert
je à la cera dicale concept
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car ici c'est super ce pays
allez sont pas inquiets quand même
[Applaudissements]
la maison des tongs
il est vous la remettons
ça fait partie du terrain et ils ont
laissé cet endroit pour que pour trouver
les fleurs de cerise et tombe par terre
et se soit beaucoup avec le béton moi je
vois que ça
je vais de surprise en surprise et
contrairement à ce qu'on m'avait dit à
tokyo on peut rentrer aussi par hasard
dans les maisons
coco
allez bien leur maison vous avez une
belle maison
[Musique]
vous nous faites vérité
comment rentiers vous
[Musique]
allez venez fait le tour par là bas ok
allez gâteau wasaï masse j'arrive
j'arrive je suis là
et l'eau on vient de france je suis
français alors j'explore les maisons du
monde entier je viens vous voir à la
vôtre je la trouve
vous avez une belle maison et
vous combien de françois
vous étiez sur la terrasse quand vous
avez je peux le voir tout de suite allé
voir allez-y
[Musique]
oui oui c'était là tu vois
c'est vraiment agréable
à barcelone là bas
malgré les apparences le code de la
construction japonais à des règles très
strictes par exemple on est censé ne pas
faire de l'ombre à son voisin en
exploitant au maximum la surface au sol
l'architecte junishi sabeg a donc fait
cette maison tout biscornu avec de
multiples ouvertures pour laisser entrer
la lumière
[Musique]
celui des fans ah oui c'est vrai
il ya une belle vision sur l'extérieur
c'est pas très grand mais n volumes et
une ouverture sur l'extérieur
la surface totale de notre appartement
fait à peu près 80 mètres carrés
nous habitons
et on loue les trois appartements du bar
a pas d'accord
il ya des rangements intégrés c'est quoi
d'accord
mais c'est ça notre sexy se
[Applaudissements]
renouveler sa carte
je
d'accord
[Musique]
toilettes
blanc tout blanc white
et la salle de bains
[Musique]
la porte rentrer dans le mur comme ça
d'accord
et là il ya la machine à laver aouita là
pour qui sourd et derrière la po placard
avec la machine à laver c'est bien pensé
les rangements
ce que je préfère dans cette maison
c'est qu'on voit le ciel
et ça donne une impression de liberté
[Musique]
ce que j'aime bien c'est que tu es ici à
la lumière et tapas devises à vue alors
qu'on est au milieu des inodes les
ouvertures sont bien faites pour la
vision des voisins sur la maison qui
abrite un mime ses traits lumineux mais
le soleil est clairement presque toute
la pièce
l'architecte a conçu la maison pour que
vient entre on se trouve on puisse voir
de soleil
[Musique]
bientôt un immeuble de 14 étages va être
construit
mais comme notre toit et en biais je
pense qu'on pourra toujours voir de ciel
[Musique]
à tokyo on manque de place c'est la plus
grande densité de population au monde la
plus forte densité de population au
monde près de 6000 habitants au
kilomètre carré pas facile de loger tout
le monde au centre ville alors il ya
deux options soit on s'agrandit sur la
mer c'est ce que font les japonais
depuis les années 50 en compactant les
ordures pour en faire des îles
artificielles
à les gâteaux
l'autre option c'est de faire des tours
très haut de construire en hauteur des
immeubles gigantesque il ya des projets
de tours complètement futuriste par
exemple la xm 4000 tours qui ferait 4 km
d'altitude 800 étage où on choisit son
altitude en fonction du climat
[Musique]
oh
vous
[Musique]
oh
monsieur obayashi qui j'ai pas encore du
bon jour lui il est là lancer le
chantier d'une tour qui va faire 600
mètres d'altitude au d'attitude presque
certainement le manteau
bonjour monsieur obayashi bonjour
comment allez vous bien merci c'est une
belle journée n'est ce pas ouais il fait
vraiment très beau
monsieur obayashi et multi milliardaire
à la tête d'un des groupes de
construction les plus puissants du pays
9000 employés 900 chantier en ce moment
dans le monde
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je viens au
japon oui oui
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
oui
c'est fabuleux
en clair
c'est beau hein et c'est très beau les
couleurs changent à chaque instant avec
la lumière oui c'est ça
[Musique]
c'est spectaculaire c'est quoi ce
matériau de la céramique céramique
lui recouverte de platine
[Musique]
oui quand même
la vue est belle d'ici là
[Musique]
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui habitent
celle là ici ce sont des ateliers
troisième cette option
la maison t-il en bois avec les tuiles
vernissées traditionnelle et latin purs
bijoux dessinés par tadao ando hyper
contemporain avec matériaux de dingue
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes en train de construire
une très très grande tour oui tout à
fait
au moins 610 m mais peut-être plus
[Musique]
mais quelle est la technologie utilisée
pour se protéger des tremblements de
terre par exemple
la structure intérieure est en béton et
autour il ya une structure métallique
quand nous avons un typhon
tremblement de terre
cela permet d'équilibrer la tour l'idée
vient du temple de orji à kyoto
ah oui vraiment oui c'est une ancienne
structure
oui il ya ce qu'on appelle le chinois
china c'est un poteau central en bois sa
police et ça ça sera vraiment unique
pour une structure de 600 m
[Musique]
mais
est-ce que je peux vraiment vous faire
confiance me veuille dias heures ok
allons-y
cdu-verts industriels utilisés pour les
télescopes
tel aspect télescope oui c'est original
c'est une seule pièce de verre ça c'est
de l'acier politique
minimale ah oui c'est pas dur
mais c'est pas du versé de l'acier pauly
d
[Musique]
c'est très impressionnante
c'est un labyrinthe
oui j'adore les brillances du béton
quand on est près du béton on voit bien
la manière dont il est travaillé
[Musique]
cette place
à cet homme
[Musique]
c'est pour purifier vos mains et votre
bouche avant d'entrer dans le pavillon
de thé
[Musique]
en faisant cela cela veut dire que vous
purifier tout votre corps est ensuite
vous pouvez rentrer dans le pavillon t
c'est un pavillon conçu pour trois
personnes
[Musique]
j'utilise cet espace pour de l'art vidéo
vidéo
pour finir la visite de cette maison
d'exception
direction le sous sol où monsieur
obayashi expose sa collection
particulière d'art contemporain c'est
beau ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
à c
orientale sas à l'époque c'est super
mais ouais c'est un 6 étoiles quand même
[Musique]
comme dans le spalle classes de la ville
bonjour terran push it chez aurel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
et
épuisant cette nuit là
oui
[Musique]
tu te fais masser moment la plus grande
ville du moule
[Musique]
j'espère que cette exploration de
l'habitat japonais vous a plu
je me suis occupé de vous ben on
s'occupe de moi maintenant
[Musique]
à la prochaine zhao et
zen
[Musique]
non